alors je vous le disais la journée a été
marqué a été des plus étonnantes à
Abidjan une journée d'abord marquée par
une image symbolique celle d'un
président Bagbo sourire aux lèvres qui a
prêté serment et qui a été investi
président de la République de Côte
d'Ivoire une investiture en total
décalage avec les premiers résultats
proclamés résultats accordant la
victoire à Alassan Ouatara alors que
s'est-il passé aujourd'hui sur place à
Abidjan Dominique derda Frédric R et
Sylvain
[Applaudissements]
baral pour principe dit-il de toujours
respecter les règles et les lois de la
République la partition aura donc été
suivie à la lettre jusqu'au
bout tout juste investi le nouveau
président de Côte d'Ivoire passe en
revue les troupes dont il est le
commandant en chef il sait mieux que
quiconque sans le soutien indéfectible
de l'armée il ne serait sans doute pas
là
aujourd'hui la cérémonie a commencé 1
heure plutôt au palais
présidentiel ent la
réiv dans la salle que des fidèles des
courtisans mais aucun diplomate
occidental les Nation Unies l'Union
européenne n' envoyé de
représentant se français le socialiste
gu de
toujour à la communauté internationale
qui lui tourne le dos Laur B un message
adresserance
Naé
a pris la couronne et la posé sur la
tête pour éviter que un autre souverain
le pape lu sur la
tête des ex comme ça on peut les les
multiper à l'infini la souveraineté de
la Côte d'Ivoire c'est elle que je suis
chargé de défendre et je n
pas avec cette élection présidentielle
si fois reporté depuis 2005 la Côte
d'Ivoire devait retrouver le chemin de
la paix la réconciliation
ce soir elle est toujours aussi divisée
avec un président qui se croyait élu
Alassan Ouara et un autre Laurent bagb
déterminé cûte que coûte à garder le
pouvoir alors